hier sind sie heiß ersehnt und lang
erwartet es hat ein bisschen gedauert
aber jetzt kommen die loris wie
empfinden wir das selber bei euch seid
ihr habt ihr arbeit weil er so viel
youtube macht seit ihr schüler seid ihr
jugendliche was wäre wie habt ihr eure
rolle oder findet ihr noch eure rolle
oder klar wissen jetzt also wissen wie
sie es jetzt irgendwie alles was
besonderes wissen einfach schüler wir
noch gegeben und noch viel mit freunden
aus oder das was jugendliche machen und
youtube kommt noch dazu du hast gesagt
wieso beruf also das ist auf jeden fall
es ist schon so beruf und man ein
bisschen doch schon viel zeit darin aber
es ist nicht so dass wir irgendwie
decken
ja du musst um 6 uhr aufstehen arbeiten
ist er wieder nach hause
es ist natürlich dort hobby und
ansonsten eigentlich alles ganz normal
dass man halt im vergleich zu allen
anderen eigentlich gar keine zeit mehr
hat einfach weil man halt noch jede
woche video raus sollte aber noch mal
kurz auf die frage medienhaus namen
gaben und übrigens retten ja die damals
schon macht hausaufgaben macht
fachschule ist doch wichtig meine schule
geht halt auch nicht gerade viel aber
auch wie vor schon gesprochen hat es ist
doch wichtig dass er nicht die schule
vernachlässigt wird sondern das hat auch
alles hat alles im gleichgewicht bleibt
das auch jetzt das wird auch nicht jetzt
nur noch 60 schreiben würden nur noch
fünf sondern auch noch relativ gut in
der schule sind weil ich mein man weiß
doch nie wie sich das alles entwickelt
wenn wir anderen davon erzählen wie viel
wir es zu tun haben fallen die die sich
auch wie wir das über packen
aber man gewöhnt sich auch dran und man
gewöhnt sich halt den stress so zu sagen
und man lernt auch damit umzugehen weise
sicherheit gut einzuplanen man muss
manchmal auch sachen verzichten können
aber irgendwie das dach dann doch
alles hinzubekommen so zeitlich also
klar man hat halt auch irgendwie
probleme irgendwie dass man muss auf das
ein und andere verzichten köln ab und zu
aber ansonsten parken geht es trotzdem
irgendwie ich weiß aber dass das ja auf
jeden fall viel zu tun haben und ich
weiß selbst nicht wie das paket also
irgendwie funktioniert deshalb weil ich
weiß nicht wie es geht halt irgendwie
ich habe mal eine gute frage zum thema
arroganz letztlich habe mich auch mit
anderen leuten unterhalten eben oder
junge fußballer die dann schon ebenso
kurz vor der profimannschaft in dem wird
ja oft nachgesagt die gucken schon so
arrogant weil sie eben schon was da
stellen die sind super jung und sie
stellen schon was da was ja bei euch
auch der fall ist aber trotzdem noch mal
nachgehakt führt nicht zu arrogant der
kugel auf die anderen nicht runter so
nach dem motto halten wir haben youtube
kanals gehofft zumindest ist das selber
kommt dann so ist das doch gar nicht
mehr arbeit nur noch irgendwie mit
kleinen lied über zusammen oder
allgemein also ich sehe mich jetzt auch
nicht irgendwie als was besonderes weil
ich sage ich nicht so ein mann steht
halt mehr dürfen was über 20 cent mehr
in der öffentlichkeit und das hat das
hat ja schon was besonderes aber es ist
jetzt nicht so dass ich mich für was
besseres für so ist es ein lied also so
hoffe ich auch nicht dass es überkommt
man muss die kamera wo es mit camping
gamma so hoffe ich hoffe ich dass es so
rüber kommt ich bin viel zu tun und
eingebildet mittels intelligenter und
schön
ich will einfach viel zu tun und
eingebildet zu sein okay für dieses war
ironie
also noch mal ganz kurz wie es genau
angefangen hat im großen ganzen haben
uns eigentlich einfach einen camcorder
keinen klein konnte ja wir haben es
einfach eine digitalkamera von unseren
eltern geschnappt haben dann ein paar 10
aufgenommen
und da kam dann irgendwie es erste video
bei raus das ist irgendwie
zusammengekettet bitte was ich hab's mit
magix geschickt